each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
we started welcome to the station the
topic of this session is called data
mining and in fact there are two ruthle
couple sections first topic is about
secure server 2005 a platform for data
money and the second half of dependency
is about applying determining protein
analysis so my name is rock weekend and
I'm the kroger manager for sequence of
determining team and join me is the dev
manager broad or team Jamie McNerney so
I work Cove a few slides and then Jamie
will all give you something more help if
you have a direct understanding of our
product so as many of you already know a
datum and secure server is way beyond
the traditional relational database
today there are lots of components in
sequel server business intelligence is
one of the key part of the secure server
so let's see what we have in the
deputies inheriting field so first the
requirement for doing business
intelligence is you need to integrate
data from various sources you need some
tools to do data acquisition from Japan
where GPU data type you also may apply
some data transformation Anna like this
for example you may do some relations
before the data is saved your
destination or you may derive some new
variables or new columns so that's the
part or called data integration or et al
once the data is gathered you apply some
analytics on top of your data warehouse
so the typical technology here is
dimension modeling motor dimensional
database also called OLAP irons data
mining using statistical machine
learning techniques are to analyze your
data and the thought patterns
laughs you want to do some report you
want to publish the findings to a nice
formatted way and send to your cut
consumers the poor consumer that is the
emails through websites so we need to
have a way to present data and to format
the result of data so those three areas
integrate analyze and report we have
different components inside secure
server 2005 one box by a lots of
different components so for the easier
part we have the secret services on five
integration services for the analyzed
face we have an elected services and for
the recording part we have reporting
services 2005 and the focus of this
topic is on the red path theatre
discovery by determining so it's the
data mining part of analysis services so
Microsoft psycho server is the first pet
relational database product that
introduced data mining inside the
relational package relation to edit
package so we enter the game in secure
server 2005 years ago and the most work
we have done is created an industry
standard as that time called Oh ddd 40
remaining inside there the important
language called a DMX there are many
extensions for sickle the release is
targeted for develop audience and it was
a vp product one product with the two
algorithms when is Microsoft this
increase the other is Microsoft crabtree
first of them come from micros of the
research so there are lot of research
that some research articles written on
the logarithm during the past five years
we have invested a lot of data money and
we will come out a product called secure
server 2005 in a couple months that's
five years ind so we really want to be
the leader in the data money space we
continued our efforts on theta minus
standard HD I for developers develop air
for
we also have comprehensive features that
we have data many algorithms cover all
sort of determine Tod including
classification association clustering
sale of forecasting all those areas we
have different algorithms and will also
want to build a determining ecosystem
which include data mining algorithm
providers tools providers application
developers as well as academic
researchers who do interior many
algorithms researchers on top of secure
server platform so we think we're
bitterly saw the leadership in this area
so here are two key message first as I
said we have a complete set of tools we
have lot of UI code as well as
algorithms we have each other ISM has a
data mining viewers and those viewers is
embeddable in your own applications so
if you your students want to view that
their money application you can host our
viewers inside so they have a lot of
time for the presentation layer we have
integrated solution so we consider data
mining as a key member in the various
intelligence family other members
including relational data warehouse or
app integration services which reach
here and the reporting services so we
have tight integration we are one of the
few product which provide all the data
abilities intelligence functionalities
in work package and we have group
integrations there another message is
embedded data mining we believe in the
future there are more numbers there will
be more more applications which embedded
in our money inside and makeup it gives
much smarter just like amazon.com today
if you buy one book it gave you the
combinations on other books right its
data mining application embedded instead
of hcp application on our website
and the last is data mining platform so
we think what our approach unlike other
small eyes these years we r platform
approach we want to make our secure
server analyzer services the d-pad form
for data money in order to that will
have to be extensible and flexible we
have algorithms previ interface which
allows to the project we develop
algorithms and plugins a sequel server
and it should be considered it equally
as the rest of secure server building
algorithms we also have a lot of men of
g models managing Authority model
development of g model those orbitals
allow users developers to build
applications on top of the platform
build web service for example so this
let's use the overall component
architecture of super silver dinner
money so dinner money is part of an
elected derivatives there are two
components in a tunnel activities window
left over the other data money and this
on top of the slide the set up hang on
applications or cry of joy models you
can use o ddd traditionally db2
connector server use a do or use XML
final itís actually if you use old only
do it Aereo its action actually
implicitly use XML for an elective so
the server and the client shall
communicate slow XML message and you
kind the rest is your client and it
doesn't need to be our windows you can
use a Linux or embedded as a client that
communicate with windows server we have
a set of interfaces which will integrate
with determine if example if you have a
data many hours and instead of secure
server you can use ETL to invoke data
money to do our table magnaflow you can
also use the potty services to do the
report based on the result of a
determining prediction queries
and bottle here is the dynamite
interfaces we have a set of algorithms
nine hours from Microsoft its most of
them are joint developed between sicko
17 and micros of the research we also
have a KPI of H I for third parties so
there are some iced we specialize in
determining algorithms are working with
us to provide some algorithms at the
plug in and it will you are your
students interest in do some projects we
can provide some technical assistance
here as well which allows your average
to be seamlessly integrated with secure
server and of course once you are with
is plug in tight secure server you've
got a lot of advantages you get
advantages are all the API models so
developers developers can build
applications use standard HD I connect
you are determining of algorithm and you
can use standard query language which is
DMX industry standard also we also
provide provide layers to connect with
different database source databases so
you don't need to worry off with the
sort in oracle DB q a tree to the theme
that Leigh is covered by our old ed so
let me talk about dmx determine
extensions for the data mining permits
for expansion for sickle this is the
initiative from Microsoft started five
years ago with a number of ice V and we
try to build a query language which is
similar to SQL for the determined users
so developers data especially happy
developers will be very familiar with
this API will be easier to butte
creditor many applications so they are
sweet type of statement first create a
nine model so this data one is very
simple just like red table to create a
money model called credit risk and we
have a set of columns you specify the
data type the key is customary
and you have gender income profession
and the last ones risk you have texted
text for data type discreet and
predictable and the last part of the
settlement is which are going to use so
if you look at this statement it's very
easy to understand it uses gender income
profession to predict credit risk based
on Microsoft decision trees and the
statement statement is training once the
model it will create it is still empty
so you need to train it and just the
algorithm where this color patterns and
those patterns will be predicted inside
my data mining container so i will use
in virtue into statement inverting to
credit risk you specify the list of
colors from the money model and then you
use a trick statement this is a part of
spinach eco the Select training dataset
from any data source elephanta call or
access or from Excel or Oracle for the
data mining and an activity if our eco
so training usually time consuming after
training you want to do produce you and
the prediction part we moderate as a
select statement so for program here I
select three columns the customer ID
credit risk the risk this is a pretty
predictable column from this money model
and also predict probability which is a
pretty fine prediction function pretty
predict ability equity risk and enjoying
to objects where is the money model it's
not relation object but you can think
about it a traditional table and the
other is a new customer table is specify
the column magnet here so this statement
returns three columns customer ID
critter it and what's the probability of
the credit risk and you can stand issue
this prediction query using a do and the
result is in a tabular format so it's
very similar to any database
applications connect your database and a
relational query and again get result
back in
tabular format so there are many models
and I set up cases so these are the
temple cases I have a sweet students I
know the agenda parent income IQ
parenting argument and the last color is
is the pretty pretty blue color with a
college player in some people are yes
and people have college pain no so these
are very simple most dynamic
applications does support simple cases
and we have a proposal another way in
which is more complicated cases we call
the next to the cases the reason is
there are the many tickets we find you
have multi value attribute customer
bought our state a product or watch the
state of movies they want to model those
multivariate repeats and this gives a
lot of expressive power for example
dispirited I have three kids customers
their demographic information but the
list of movies they like press the
scholar reg reg the disease movies I can
predict customers gender based on the
list of movies they watched first the
their IQ and the age for example oh I
can predict the list of movies they like
based on their demographic information
oh I can predict the list of other
movies they like based on the movies
they already put purchase or watched so
next table helps you to more the data
complicated business problem easily and
you don't need to worry up the pivoted
the algorithm not accurate of the layer
before before I window they have any
infrastructure code we have you to pivot
it your tear and give you all the
coloration comes so you are poised for
you to develop algorithms you can
directly consumed the converted data for
you so it is expressive power as well as
there's a lot of time for each year you
don't need to manually create a very
wide table with all those colors finally
columns
we have a rich set of algorithm as I
mentioned we don't have time to go each
of them but most of them we have
research papers that the first wave
Microsoft at entry it's the pod bus
classification and the liberation
clustering we have to building
clustering algorithm one year the
kidneys the other is am
expectation-maximization we also the
support automatically discover the
number of clusters within a data set we
have time series wisdom and the
algorithm is based on research paper
written by david hackman it's called up
auto regression tree so to use using
regression tree technique to forecast
the future values of a time series it
also find correlations among different
series for example you can build a model
with 5,000 not stock stock tickers for
the past two years and it finds out
quite a bit dare stop value has strong
correlation to Microsoft future value it
may end up using death period previous
value but Michael totally Microsoft
previous value to predict future value
for Microsoft we have sequence
clustering algorithm which is a hybrid
of sequence and a clustering algorithm
this is very useful for creek street
anna like this so each webpage click web
page is either LG is a state of the
sequence and the transition is a model
using the sequence and you can group
customers or web visitors together based
on their navigation patterns you can
also analyze it for purchase as well or
in the academic you know students which
caught it they take some people take the
course in this order some students take
courses the other order and you can
group them faizan the similarity
association algorithm the one we use is
very classic appear clearer type of
algorithm but we have very efficient
cementation then we have now you've is
16.9 you base a new low network mercadeo
position puts at home and also the rapid
we have text mining technique which is
also picnic transport from Microsoft
Research Asia it is analyzed your
English text and the extract na and na
praises was convert the o structured
data to the structure variation of all
night we can apply a naive Bayes boiled
up with you classify your documents so
now my colleagues anywhere show you some
demos of our product see if I'm
leveraging switched over here we go my
name is Jamie mclennan and as always
said I'm development manager for
analysis services what I'm going to do
right now is just give you a flavor of
what we're offering sequel server 2005
so you can see a little bit maybe how
you can apply it back at home in your
research or your class work or also have
maybe you can plug into this environment
and why the advantages and some of the
choices that we made the first thing
that you'll see is that our environment
here it's actually this environment
visual studio so our data mining
environment is visual studio and the
reason why it's visual studio is that
most of these projects we're doing data
mining or if you're doing any kind of
kind of business intelligence like an
OLAP cube or reporting whatever you're
actually getting a development project
you're developing something which you're
going to want to share out so just by
being part of Visual Studio that allows
us to do some things like integrate with
source code control and a lot of other
kind of neat features which you have for
that kind of environment another thing
lets me do is if you're familiar with
visual studio as visual studio has a
solution concept then you see it says
solution up there and we have one
project in there with that called AC I
can have multiple projects in there i
could have a recording services project
in there which is where i'm going to
show my results I could have some code
projects in there which on maybe our
algorithms I'm going to integrate into
heat into this system or stored
procedures I'm going to write as other
projects or have a web front-end project
all sides of same solution so it keeps
it all together for the end user or the
end development team
that's going to be working on different
parts they can all share the same thing
so it's kind of a really interesting
feature just to begin with before we
even get into what the data mining part
is now what we're looking at right here
I already started the project and I
created something called the data source
view the data source view basically
where you select your tables that you're
going to do mining on and what I did
here these are actually tables from a
sequel server database but they could
just be easily table from a db2 database
on oracle database or even access
database intentionally you know Excel
and many other different backends we
also support data mining from any source
because you can do data mining in
integration services which allows you to
pull data from any data source and push
it into your mining models I'm not going
to be able to show that now but if you
want to do data mining of a flat file
you can do that directly integration
services and also with some tricks you
could do it in this environment as well
so the data port view environment allows
you to manipulate your data source and
kind of look at in different ways it
also lets you we have some rudimentary
at data exploration tools so the first
table is what we call case table and it
just has a demographic information this
data is a movie survey i did about
people from people in microsoft just
about their movie watching behaviors and
you have columns such as their marital
status who and their family pics what
movie they watch you still love doing
microsoft erwise pick the models and
why's their husbands pick the movie they
watch how often they watch movies and so
on and so forth that kind of information
and then we had these other tables in
here such as this hobbies table and if i
look at this table and see what it looks
like it has basically two columns the
customer ID and their list of hobbies
right so one customer has many hobbies
so it's that you know kind of a
one-to-many relationship in this table
and this is how we do the nesting so
this is how i can say i have a nested
table so for when i create my model i'm
gonna have all the demographic
information in there but i also had the
list of hobby that this person likes so
it gives me a lot of expressive power
it's actually very interesting the kind
of things you can do it for example
quality health services in israel they
built a model to determine to predict
whether or not a senior citizens health
is going to deteriorate within the next
year using the previous two years of
data and to do that they had all the
demographic information and previously
using other products what they had to do
is search all the other information
manually do you know quote unquote data
mining you know where you're really
digging through the data to come up with
attributes that they had to figure out
which other thousand attributes are
going to use and put in their database
and do mining on well what they did with
our product is they said oh you know
i'll just create a nested table of all
the medications will use they're using
i'll take it make a nested table of all
the types of specialists they're seeing
I'll make a nested table of all their
chronic illnesses that we know about and
use those as inputs to my data to
predict whether or not their help and
they ended up having ten different nessa
table so they actually essentially they
cross their information across 11
different domains to solve one problem
so it gave them a much bigger expressive
power so skipping ahead i'm going to go
right into our wizard which help you
create models and i'll right click here
and say new mining structure which pops
up our data mining with it the first
thing you asked is whether want to data
mining against relational source or a
pube and we'll just leave relational
sort selected and now I don't actually
get list out the techniques so here list
out all the algorithms that we have in
our server now actually what it does
actually goes to the server and
discovers a list of albums that are on
that server so if you wrote your own
plugging algorithm to your students or a
plugin Elron already bought a plugin out
going for a third party it would just
show up on this list you don't do
anything it just shows up on this list
on the client side and everything else
works the same so I'm going to leave it
with decision trees for now click Next
ask what data store if you I want and
now it says how I want to use the tables
the customers my case table and let me
just take a couple take the hobbies on
that they have and their favorite
channels as as nested tables now click
Next and now it tells me how do I want
to use these columns like to make this
window bigger this is actually a
wonderful new feature within the head
before which is just making dialogues
bigger it's an amazing feature so I'll
just going to click here and just make
everything input here
and what I'll do is I'll make the the
channels and hobbies inputs as well and
what let me go is say look let's try to
predict whether or not somebody's going
to own their house let's predict how
often they go to the movies at the
theaters and we'll also predicted
favorite hobbies phone thing is kind of
interesting is one thing we've done to
make data mining easier just kind of
wipe out a lot of the predefined kind of
the pre ideas about data money so
normally in the alignment bottom I
couldn't go and say our free printable
targets right but here i can say
creepers will particles of handle
another thing we do is like our
clustering of them this is the same
dialogue that you'll get it either
clustering diagram algorithm our
association rules algorithm it's not
specific so we can actually do
predictions with clustering algorithm if
anybody's use clustering before they
know it's not very great for prediction
well you can do it it's not something we
prevent the user and then down the road
we have accuracy charts that tells you
that the question I can probably do a
very good job unless you're predicting
gets your first data so I'll just go
ahead and click next here on this data
on here it lets me select the content
types let it know whether things are
categorical or continuous and the data
types and I can go in here hit detect
and it'll run a little heuristic which
says you know it only had two values and
it only get discrete even though the
date along a numeric data types I'll
click next here and give it a name so my
mind is structurally the same name my
mind Marvel inside the structure I'll
give it another day customers dt4
decision tree now I would I have here
the reduced view of my data source to
you just what I've seen before in the
column joined model I'm not gonna go to
live here but this is the mining
structure which is a new term we also
have this idea of a mining model a
mining model is inside the structure and
it says take those columns and those
data bindings that it shows before and
associate them with some data associated
them with an algorithm right so I can go
in here and say here's my algorithm
decision trees I can do funny stuff like
oh instead all our our nice set of
advanced parameters for people who like
to tweak of that kind of stuff and
change how the columns are used I can go
in here do something but let's create
another mining model and i'll call it
customers CL and i'll use the clustering
algorithm and click ok oops i use
association rules no I don't want to kid
you you try it again customers CL and
use Microsoft clustering there we go and
then I'm also going to create another
one and i'll call it customers naive
Bayes naive Bayes advertise in its
metadata that it doesn't support
continuous variable so it tells me that
these variables aren't going to be
supported so it will actually continue
yes and you see that those columns that
are continuous that markets ignore so
what I have here is one mining structure
i define kind of the domain of a problem
and then i can have many different
instances of models in that in that
solution now what happens actually is it
reads the data once and put that into a
nice compressed cash and then it feeds
that to all those algorithms in parallel
so it kind of gives some advantage of
trail of processing just at the top end
and then if you have your own algorithms
you can put those in here too just like
anything else they're not there's
nothing special about a Microsoft
algorithm versus a third-party I'll road
so another thing I'm going to do here
exactly for the clustering I'm going to
go ahead and ignore these nested tables
just for our sanity sake and then what
I'm going to do is deployed it through
the server so really what I've done so
far that created the file to my hard
drive which just have the XML metadata
of those models and of those objects and
I'm going to deploy it to my server it
creates the objects on the server that
reads the data and then go ahead and
process all the models and this is the
point in the presentation or we just a
have tell birdie watch a spinny yeah
hypnotic little device that we have here
to say bye sequel server by six
we're actually come up with a whole line
of spinny t-shirts and a stuffed animal
so yeah it created it process all the
models and now let me go ahead and
browse some of these models so the first
thing I do is browse my decision tree
model and that's I know and here's our
decision tree viewer as that we said you
can take these viewers you can put them
in your own application since you're
creating your own algorithms to you can
actually write your own you wrote your
own viewers and plug them in here I can
actually write my own tree viewer and
have it we place this tree viewer for
the user who want to or I can take the
tree viewer and view my models with it
with using my algorithm or write my own
completely new viewers as well so we
have a lot of nice little features here
you can you know go back and forth you
can shade things by where where this
hobby is this is acting in theater the
tree for acting the theater and you can
see that they're very that the most
concentration is where the hobbies
Museum and arts exist and one thing also
you see here that they look at it we
have museums and art with and hobby
movies intelligent with the hobby though
we have marital status also play then so
you can see the interplay between the
demographic information and attends
actual information right here in the
model now there are multiple targets
like I showed you I click three things
as brick table well it's not just three
things actually every hobby becomes a
predictable target when I look at here I
still have a tree for every possible
hobby so I can go down here for business
and investing and I see you have a tree
for business and investing I can go to
tree for comics animation and so on and
so forth I can see all these different
trees well another thing we already have
the dependency network which kind of let
you see the forest for the trees and
just take seconds them up I always have
to use that line because it's tough
decision trees and you can zoom in here
and you kind of see the relationships
you can drag this down use the strong
relationships like what's related to
museums and art bring that up you see
books and literature photography acting
a theater or the strongest things
followed by news and media and so on and
so forth so you get some good ideas of
how that would how that works let me go
on browse our clustering model
our clustering viewer question while
it's really nice because it kind of you
look at it you're like okay well with
that that's neat but so what so what it
really does is it take alert clusters
which are kind of abstract and throws
them on the surface and said let's try
to get the clusters that are similar
close to each other in the ones that are
different far apart so cluster sticks is
probably not very similar to cluster 5
but you know cluster 1 and 5 might be
closed and also you see the cluster 1
and 2 have more people in them I can
also go in here and say for example
where are the people who own their
houses well these are the people that
own their house is these are the people
that rent their houses where are the
people with who let's look at theater
frequency people will go to movies daily
well that's nobody how about people who
are the movies monthly almost every
cluster as a good country good
concentration weekly only these guys
over here going weekly so you can kind
of get a view of your clusters there and
there's lots of other views as well I'm
not going to go into them all just for
crime snakes but do with a nice view
here which says show me the difference
in cluster one everybody is not in
cluster 1 and this is applicable to
everything actually there's a paper
written on sequel server 2000 using our
clustering algorithm where they did
something scientific study based on the
impact of underwater wood on greenhouse
gases which I don't really actually
remember the results of the study but
they said they did this study previously
using manual methods and it took several
weeks if not months and they didn't
using our clustering algorithm and they
did the same research that the same
results in about three days so it's very
very nice now I'm going to skip the
accuracy chart so we can move forward
and this goes quickly over to our money
model prediction pain now prediction is
where we think that you know there's a
lot of benefit you can do predictions
you can embed predictions and
applications there's lots of different
things actually one thing that kind of
always kind of mentioned is I think
there's two sides of data mining there's
descriptive analytics that's showing you
what I just showed you now is the data
mining did it just showed you a bunch of
stuff that maybe didn't know before and
then there's predictive analytics which
is applying that against new data which
I'm showing you right now so I'm going
to switch this over to
singleton mode which allows me to
actually enter in value of what I want
to do is I want to say what are the
possibly the top two hobbies that people
are going to want accidentally delete
that week that and they say give me a
prediction function where I'm going to
predict Bobby's and i want to say what
are the top two most likely hobby for a
person and i'll just go in here and say
the person's 35 they have a you know a
bachelor's degree their mail their other
hobbies are they camping and computers
and they own the house what this does is
actually generate the query like that we
showed you which says select the top two
hobbies from my model prediction join
there's my input right so it's very
simple very easy very easy to create
this kind of stuff there's a lot of
things you can send here i could send at
this point i can send a singleton query
like this i can send a query to
relational database i can send a
parameter from from the client so i can
have my data gathered on the client and
send that as a road set parameter to the
server I can have another data mining
query in there where I predict from
another model and send the output to
that model into a different model so
there's a lot of flexibility you have
there as well so I look at the result I
know the results going to be and we'll
find out that we have this nested result
actually let me just go back here and
just for fun so you can see kind of get
an idea of what it looks like let's
actually take the egg and put that here
as well ok it's not let me do that let's
go here and off a comma T dot age and if
I look at the result now you see I have
my row my face row and a nested table
the results and it says that the this
person is likely to watch like science
technology and travel and if I go back
to my design
I can go back here and change my hobbies
pages Nia add acting in theater fitness
food and cooking and get rid of camping
and hiking and change will stay make it
a woman with a master's degree who's 40
and then his results and now it says
books literature inside technology so
you can get different builds can do a
lot of what if kind of analysis here you
can take these queries and embed them
into your results so the idea here is
give you an idea of the flexibility to
platform there's a lot of other things
you can do with the platform other than
this when you right here on algorithms
you don't use that you don't worry about
that language our infrastructure
basically takes all the data from
whatever data source trace it stream of
active value pairs and send those to
your algorithm so all your element has
to deal with the stream of active value
pairs and it's it's it's up to you to do
with that the only thing difference
between I would say our implementation
of an algorithm in our system and then
implementing an algorithm on your own is
that generally people don't have to
worry about cases of different lengths
so if you're running a data mining
algorithm usually you think of the old
model which is kind of a square model so
you know that your cases are all going
to be have ten attributes if it's the
first page that set attributes well in
our case you could have thousands of
attributes and actually we've run models
where we have 750,000 attributes they
run just fine so um that's the demo of
sequel server 2005 data mining and I
wanted to transfer it over to our way
long who's going to talk about her
datamining work with protea now thank
you
yes currently now but you could actually
write an algorithm which calls the other
algorithm that does the vacuum boosting
for you actually since everything is an
XML for analysis everything is
automatically a web service you just
have to long open up the port de cv Thor
to you're on you're on you're on your
client and it is web server if you want
to write this down there's a website
called sequel server data mining calm
and on that website we actually have an
XML for analysis example where it allows
you to it reads all the metadata and
comes up with a query builder and you
can click what you want a query and it
will send an XML request then get the
XML response any more questions yes it
is reasonably easy it's actually it's
much easier than we had in sequel server
2000 actually the the API level where
you write your algorithms is that the
exact same place at the eggs API level
where the Microsoft algorithms are
written so if they have no more or less
functionality than the Microsoft
algorithms and it's a much lower level
API we have it right now the API is a
common api's p plus plus it's not your
comp stuff is just all in process but we
also are working on a sample for a
managed code of C sharp or vb.net kind
of implementation as well that'll be
released as a sample on how you can
write code that way tickle server data
mining that come one question
ok so the text binding we have the
question is on display more text mining
the text mining that we have our two
transformations which are in integration
services and the transformation for term
extraction which finds the noun and noun
phrases in your in your English document
it documents and then term look up which
takes new documents and says you know
this term belongs in this document it
does word semi and does a couple other
things that they actually find key
phrases so it doesn't necessarily find
this one term we can find many so find
data mining is one term instead of two
separate terms and then you can actually
pump those into your your OLAP cubes or
reports or on data mining models are you
ready ok we'll take will take question
Decker's ok so from for the rest of the
next hour half an hour also I'm going to
share with you the projects that have
found is partly funded by the defense of
the consumer award here and the project
is called can you hear me the project is
a cop motif space basically of course I
will give you a offer you about her what
this project is about and how computer
science so actually research can help
greatly in a intense magnification
myself came from the background of a
database and data mining and during the
past three years I start to look into
bio informatics notifications and the
primary access agreement at start
without her driving application of my
research in computer science and math
and the things that start to do that has
become more more interesting and this is
just the one project I have currently
working on at unc-chapel Hill during the
less ranked second I talked briefly
about her a mining protein and mining
hydrant from protein
sir as I mentioned before that proteins
and machinery of life under the mat the
big challenge that foul it is try to
addresses to determine how protein
powders and and we all know that
proteins function is determined by its
structure and therefore the scientists
the happy working on cataloguing new
protein structures at a very excited
explanatory and all the currently other
structures are deposited me to a protein
data bank this is a publicly available
accurate escutia phase resources that
anybody can who's interested in kind of
came to that you can see that clear the
rate has been growing exponentially so
if you look at a protein structure as it
is I'm going to share a little bit more
detail with you actually it is a large
molecule basis it's a long linear chain
of amino acid and the according to some
stable but dynamic three-dimensional
shape so that can function and in a
relatively stable sake we we also know
that for many of the proteins actually
only a small structure in the protein
directly responsible for its function
and we often refer the master visual
motifs here is the US just a free sample
of protein after they're coming I
Brister pics free samples from three
different protein structures and the
highlighted area are the functional side
I see some have called active side of
the protein you can see that there are
just performed by a very small number of
aromatic
and it served as their the functional
side of the protein and from now on
elektra further micra specialties and
our our emphasis in this project is to
develop computational method to fast and
efficiently discover all those
specialties so that the ballast can use
them to form value to have positive for
your test so the overall structure of
motif space after consists of several
conversational component and we start
with the protein structures available in
protein data bank and we all know that
scientists have been doing a great job
in cat in grouping protein structures
according to their similarities in their
instruction and the and the functions
here is the on the right hand side asa
it's just the high-level protein
classification after in a coke its
patients in this particular one is based
on a structural similarity so came in
any protein family what we can do is
that we have a motif manner basically it
take the protein structure out of the
protein data bank and look for recurrent
spatial motif so they think they are the
motifs that occur murder at the very
high frequency within his family and the
next step is to apply a filter on those
special move here just to put the lights
out those ones that occur rarely in the
rest of the protein work the notion here
is that we want to fund something that
highly associated with this particular
protein family that we want to study
because we want to find out what are the
characteristics of this job working
family that are responsible for for
example for the common function shared
by the school problem
proteins we want to be able to
understand how they function sand which
park are planning to they're actually
responsible for their function so we
call them families difficulties and with
the positive the motive green in the
database so and then this motif can be
used to construct a predictive model and
to predict for example protein function
so a new structure comes in and they'll
go through this the country bar and then
we will be able to tell whether or not
sister how likely this this new
structure has this particular function
and we'll also look up at the literature
in biomedical domain and look for a free
to extract external knowledge that are
has been developed by scientists and put
them in a knowledge base and the order
to make for yourself is the the the
information or knowledge we discovered
we will have keep navigator basically
this navigator will talk to each
individual component and enable a user
to interact wisdom and if you look at
the whole picture you can see that your
several important components that can
view to the whole project and if you
look beneath each of the component you
can see that I tricked this are the the
area of research that involved each
component okay you can see that in the
motif manager I'm going to focus on
today so it's nonstop worth mining and
then for the next one is the motive
filter actually associated with the
feature selection Association discover
it and the to build the classifier we
used across education vampyre the next
one Thea information retrieval and tecmo
in the blocks it is a largely I mean
that navigate her comeback a benefit
from a normal realization technique
after these are the errors that we're
currently working out and to develop her
normal computer science research so I'm
just going to share with you this motif
minor and if time allowed i'll show you
a brief demonstration to see how that to
show the idea so let's go back to the
protein structure available in protein
data bank in order to analyze them will
have to be able to represent them in
clean and precise way so in protein data
bank if you look at the data file
actually they are represented by point
in a three-dimensional space was
available there is for each I come in a
protein you have 3d coordinate you can
sync data what's what's the input to the
whole system is via a set of point with
your sweetie three dimensional
coordinates but what you need to keep in
mind is that they have four errors and
know if they're it just like you have a
protein structure and then you take a
picture of that and then you for each
point you have it location within some
some error box so
starting from that point and then what
in the motive space what were the first
step what we are doing to represent
azria the protein structure so that we
can keep the essential information for
for the money off for visual motifs what
we choose to do is to rather than by
grass we're no corresponding to a mere
hundred residues and edges corresponding
to potential impactors and were
investigating the trade-offs between the
complexity of the boyfriend of the
information we need to captures and you
can imagine there's many different ways
to construct the graph to represent the
protein structure and hours to ourself
we have tried several different
approaches and next I'm going to share
with you one of them so no but no matter
what where you decide to represent your
protein structure by class after you
have fended actually a special motifs
that I show you before actually one of
them is also highlight data on the top
left the figure as can be can correspond
to a sub graph in the in the graph
representation so basically you can see
once we savage this correspondence the
exercise of minus beta motifs becomes
our funding frequent software in a set
of graphs and the challenge here is the
graph isomorphism which has been proven
to be np-complete so next I'm going to
share with you how we are going to ask
you what what we have been doing to make
a beauty of the variance of the protein
glasses that allow us to develop a
thermal efficient algorithm
before I go into that i'm going to show
you just the one way represent we have
used to represent protein structures by
glass it's called almost beyond accurate
developed by my colleague texturing and
his student at unc-chapel hill and their
paper actually conversational geometry
research and their favorite pub you lost
your shoulder what we're doing here is
that you can see one way to represent
the before i show this done I want to
I'm such that this is not the unique way
to represent it this is just a
reasonable way to do this I can to be I
can give ourselves quite good result so
what we're looking at here is that if we
select a four point in in a
three-dimensional faith and then we look
at whether or not we can form an empty
sphere that that those four points
happen to pass through the surface and
with of course no other point included
in the Indus empty sphere if thats the
case after we can connect each pair of
this tattoo pointer with eggs so the
notion here is that we want to define
some kind of a spatial neighborhood with
no interference of on another point
though that's why we want this empty
sphere and as I mentioned before well
that actually that's a standard
definition scale on interpolation and as
I mentioned before there's noise Xena in
the in the location of each point so
therefore we want to allow some kind of
error and what we're doing here we could
all of them in basically we allow of a
primary that we have additional
parameters an optimal basic just defines
the maximum area that were allowed per
point in terms of their location so
basically we allow is going to perturb
cause any direction by an amount of
patmos ethanol
for doing that flexibility if we can
still constructed mp3 then we think that
it should be an actor so by this
definition you can see that the
traditional representation of design in
translation suggest a special case with
epsilon equal to 0 so this is just an
animation to show you that that after
you move allow yourself move the point
later on and there's the possibility of
for constructing new edges so this red
way just a new acts that are allowed if
you allow some perturbation so if you
married is the restaurant started from
zero to positive infinitum so basically
you can allow them to perturb in any way
one and then you look at the edges with
distance less than a certain stress food
then you have fun this country tsinghua
basically want to alarm Ohio 30 you have
fun you're going to have more and more
edges sereno your grass and the our
external 1.0 Axia I saw a default value
so i can represent the protein
structures at last now the next question
is the how do we fund special piece
which is how do we find sub graphs that
are corresponding to the special kids
and we formed a cesta as the block
mining problem and in this case we want
to find frequent sub graphs because we
want to find special motifs that occur
the almost ever cooking within the
family but also up for the next a visa
is had to occur rarely the rest of in
the rest of the protein world but the
first one who found out those one that
occurred frequently within the family so
this is a cure exactly the frequent sup
of mining problem and for those of you
who are not familiar with the problem
basically just one card video oil was
the problem is about if you start with
the protein as for a black database of
three graphs and there you set your
threshold as the two out of the surface
we are for all the sub graphs that
occurring at least the cool out of this
request so on the bottom of this these
are all the sub graphs that occur at it
is twice in your database so this is a
definite working hope you'll think about
the combination 300 it's very
complicated and it's very time-consuming
so a lot of our effort has been
investigating how to develop a fast and
efficient algorithm to allow this this
kind of conversation when of our
approach is the face of canonical we
define some canonical form to represent
via the graph in the subway and so that
we can have some nice property on that
is total out some combination of Judah
so this is at a high level we we use the
canonical adjacency matrix and the wiki
find her so we firstly if we look at it
and are adjacent to matrix is basically
if you put on layout to the node in the
graph along the end no and then if you
entry this corresponding to the country
to add to the edges that to come back to
note and they will put 0 there is just
no ads here so is the simple
representation its adjacency matrix and
you can see that for a given graph the
adjacency matrix is not unique you can
have many different adjacency matrix one
corresponding to each combination of
flow of your node along the diagonal of
in the matrix and what we define the
canonical one should be the one that
maximized some some function and in this
case is a code we define so we can
coordinate nowise the additional metrics
if you want you to track the one that
maximize this coding and the yarder took
put this other week which defines the in
this particular example we will see well
it's alphabetic order lexicographical
order so that
but but in the real water you would have
preferred ways to define order between
no acid so if that case the actually the
leftmost one door that corresponding to
the maximum Cody and we call it
canonical adjacency matrix and look at
this one okay so after that basically
all the Sun for the preference of where
we're interesting would naturally be
represented as in the tree structure
basically each of the two entry in the
tree corresponding to a stop work and
can be represented by canonical agencies
world and from I'm due to the time comes
from nothing to be able to share with
you the detail the technical details of
how this can speed up but I'm just to
give you a high level of summarization
so for the automation feel that we use
the via the graph representation for
Kurt instructor and where we used to add
is truly encode potential impact on the
plane rises so which means that the
ground come from has some spatial
locality and basically you will not
connect amino acids that have further
apart you all increasing those ones that
are you some special neighborhood and
this will translate into a of a nice
property of a boundary degrees in in the
graph also we use the a priori property
that that can be applied to any frequent
parapet remaining algorithm to help us
to to guide our basically mining of
broken sub work and the basics at the
end super graph of an infrequent sub
graph is infrequent so basically this
CUDA a suggest that we need to check on
small staff work for people go to bigger
chakra and this would help us to
eliminate unnecessary of a morphism cat
and as I showed you the canonical form
we were using which allow us to reduce
the awarded redundant examination and we
use that first explore original all
comfortable with frequent stuff works so
that we can use the original call sama
incremental at maccas on track basically
we want to reuse the result on smaller
sub graph i have had two before so we
don't we don't protect it and also this
alpha last fourth of four petal memory
of salvation so we stop our web
developer several different version of
our rock mining stock of many algorithms
extra specially tuned for mining special
motifs of health law protein structure
basically we will utilize some special
prophecy you can see that these are not
general graph if its general Axton is
already improving their surgery the
cracks of graph isomorphism nice though
it's an elite problem but especially due
to the fourth property that we have we
have this would allow degenerate
interesting algorithm set to mount for
ourself to be in such a dilemma so now
what we are doing is we want to
incorporate more interesting features to
our algorithm one of the mixer we want
to allow substitution of amino acids
types in the sub graph we are
considering and we want to allah i
support more dynamics and the geometric
constraint so here before i show you the
demo i want to give you a few examples
that we tried along our path and sort of
for the past 23 years after the first
family protein family we started is
sermon positive and this in this table I
think this is the 38 motifs that we
discovered that her is specifically to
this the protein family
actually I felt them and now in one of
the protein structures that you can see
this the colorful ball ball they are VM
I'm in an acid residues part of the
stage normal kids and we have 38 help
them you can see data actually many of
the spectrum of peeps are heavily
overlap with each other and if you look
harder to send her part and productive
the active site of this girl of this
family of proteins this is the the
pattern experiment easily discovered
based on the scope acadia the set of
protein we are using is classified by
skolko version 1.6 65 released the
patent offices on under three and the
fifth then there's new structures become
available and we use those one at the at
the past and that this idea at seven
proteins FATCA whose structure available
after that and this are actually our
protein classifier identified them as
the label demise services and then we go
ahead to check each one of them and the
final actually on all of them are
actually serve produces even though they
were not originally labeled in the scope
by the end of 2003 and our address some
of them are currently labeled at seven
cottages officially in esco there's a
gesture a new release of horoscope I
think it's 1.67 and a caddis success we
go ahead and say well webinar his
because we just had a lot in that one
particular family are or this sir
general Harran can be applied to all the
coding family
and they've that the case then undo
actually there will be a lot of
potential in health authorities so to
design their well attack so we go ahead
to pass another family which is CR 15
proteases and these are the family
specific proteins of the family specific
motifs which we put out and actually for
if I don't know what amounts to a
visible from from your side is the
yellow highlighted the residue after dr
d activa center of this family and i
want to mention that actually for this
exercise and we didn't incorporate any
of this domain knowledge which is look
at the structure of the protein and a
desk are all the information we use for
the mine exercise and then we look at
okay what added vehicle motifs and
whether or not cuz the result makes them
in ambala t so on the left hand side
actually these are dia i highlighted
these are the active are active site the
motifs in wolf investor cover those
active site and you can see that and in
this up anyone's function actually this
exactly corresponding to it's just a
different committee slightly different
akin to the one put a figure in the in
the right hand side after wiki rockets
will have a favor from from this paper
they recorded so some this idea the
important structure that snoring active
sites and so if we zoom back so that we
can see all the stuff special more kids
we put out all together and see what are
they and what we just look at this park
without active site and what are they
spark then the definitional pressure and
then we found out accurate
these are the Hubble for hydrophobic
finding pockets so which also carries a
biological function so we're pretty
happy with this if we have kinda member
to show you a little bit just on this
particular family so after that well
we'll go ahead a tool to try something
more interesting and actually more
adventures which is the function of
function difference of often structure
so you know that yourself exists the
many protein structures that people
don't know just have no idea about you
but what are your function is and we
want to use of course we want to use our
computational means to try to infer with
how the possible functions they carry
and and this and this is just one
example we have tried on the left hand
side is the family car hmph and we found
49 and special motifs that have specific
to this family and this art piece
highlighted in the in the mid of that
and on the right hand side is a often
structure that actually was a task aside
target that people tried to project to
the fold and a structure of the of the
13 now we know the structure but feel we
don't know the the function and that
because there's no good sequence and
structure lineman to any of the known
protein so still remains a puzzle and
what we find out actually this
particular protein contains 30th of the
foliage I'm a fisherman tipsy we fund
for that family and there's just a
recent literature reporting data
actually someone symbologies the fun in
developed athleta this particular
protein looks like carries functions
similar to dr. family and they recording
them in one of their present paper
and this is the second example we have
athlete it is just a different term
protein family and we have 62 facial
motifs pants and after this town is very
small wine I only have four members at
the end up from 2003 and this is again
another orphan structure with a new
function and still it's not classified
yet and with the any function I fell far
I think a few months ago and we find out
how to this particular protein contains
46 out of the six to visual motifs we
find it associate with that family and
and the more interesting is like we find
out there's actually several proteins
new proteins that people just discovered
after have worried I have some structure
similarity with this particular from the
enemy all already the official labeled
ERISA with with that family so so
there's some evidence to suggest that
her the predictor model we're building
can be served as a very good verbal
model to generate hypotheses for validus
to to be to design develop test okay so
if we interest in the data mining and
various magic the techniques that we are
developing this other little papers that
we published recently and of course the
project the most part of a successful so
that his participation flow of the
collaborator from different field to
make this happen so now I'm going to
show you a little demo
you
ok so I'm going to load 7
so this are seven protein pharma 15 of
15 proteases and save the time i'm going
to set my fresh food increase hi so I'm
looking for special mopey that occurred
in at least six of the seven and protein
and the we we want the special motif
have at least a Content six amino acid
residues and I'm going to study the the
job so what is happening here is that
this education will go back to a server
at UNC which is which directly caused
the approaching data bank to retrieve
all the structures and does everything
is computer on the flag will replicate
the effort will have to wait a little
bit and kill dia the results returned so
it does is that once it retrieved the
structure busy target for each protein
is a list of all coordinates associated
with each item and and then we can track
the grass and then we use the graph
mining algorithm to mine freakin
subclass and then we map them back to
the to the core team work and they're
not reading them and the middle block
rhinos empty here those eventually
hopefully show a list of motifs that
actually is showing up now and that's
shared by this at least six out of the
seven a structure so so you wish to like
one of them after we can see what haria
other motifs that are contained by this
stuff this particular family and then if
we want to see where are they and how
they look like
just take a little bit one ok so this
start actually this highlighted area
they start the pasta special move here
and there and actually discontent to all
of this this group are the active center
after of this earth and this funk this
family of proteins and if you can look
at it these are the lives of motifs and
you can even highlight them out if they
go down and look at the major one of her
another so now i also want to show you
that so if why i choose two of them i
can say that what are the things share
to buy this and if i want to just see
whether or not i mean i want to show two
protein structure together aligned
according to the special motif i find
out actually the Graduate feel the one
that had just showed you before and the
magenta one is the second protein so
actually you can see that this this fear
it may not be very visible here but ha
so in that area dr. young that's the
motive and the dispersion multi-effect
her that I'm in 15 and use this to align
it to to align this to go protein
structure actually this particular motif
that cover fear that you've signed
healthier of the protein we can see that
I can give particular example that see
the second important has been aligned
pretty well with part of via the first
protocol the first line so is the big
one and the second one is just smaller
and then they happened to be aligned
pretty well if we align both based on
your ex
the special motifs pathology exercise
and in January for if you play with this
and with many different without
affording families and you will see that
in general to proteins may not align
very well and I mean globally so part of
the milan pretty well and the rapid part
of me maybe just the branch out and I
know because the if they aren't very
well it always along well then you I
mean you can easily find them by global
structure alignment so the beauty of
this project is that it does not require
that at last part of the protein
structure show some similarities we just
put that out you can see that
particularly it's much much more
difficult one to support this kind of
local alignment and this is what we can
support in this case actually and this
is just showing one point example of one
of the spatial more peeps that were able
to find out and you can see that this
part little heartedly the exit center so
any questions
working with biologists what about the
culture that very good biology has
harnessing the power of computing
confirmed their clients you've been able
to get your biology
yeah I think that's a very good question
so when we started project I talked to
my collaborator from the other side were
frequently and I'll see 94th on with
higher the reactions kind of magnitude
based a crash show them what i do and
listen no we're not interesting this
were interesting something else which is
always different from what I show them
even though I thought at all you said
your interest in this lifetime I'll
communion wine Lena know they always
tell that was not what I mean laughs I'm
so so basically there's a learning curve
there that allow us to communicate so at
the beginning of course that when I show
it will show you a couple of examples
like how it happened to sort of like the
special motifs contains the active so
basically all those proof of contact to
give them the the confidence that you
know this is a good system for you
because Fordham who designed and
implemented erick sermon is very costly
and it's hideous and take long time and
they don't want to go ahead take a
random hypothesis so they won't have
some handle for confidence before the
go-ahead to do that but i'm happy to say
at this stage are we we have developed
some kind of found in the classical
director that's why we that's why before
the later part of the 1i showed to us
out it's on the function or inference
basically nobody know what to do the
function of of all those offer
instructors are and then on when we we
were able to show them to go to the
ballot is that they're very interesting
that so they because intended because
because of the all these other work that
we have we have done in the past but
just a tool so that rediscover what
already what they already know
so then now they feel more and more
confidence data that they want to I mean
use this one through as a way to help
them to generate your hypothesis so I so
I want to make sure that I understand
your question so you we only met emotive
this is a motive that are formed by
multiple after we we have we have look
at that and even I can't let me see what
I did have something to see are you have
a backup track for this so this RV yet
if you look at a green or red there's
our two motifs we discovered and if you
look at your on this religious structure
actually the Spanish to each other and
the only reason that if they are
discovered as to motif is that there are
some flexibilities there dramatically so
they occur if you look at different
protein so that it won't will they won't
be able to be covered by a single motive
but they have fun with after after we
find out of motifs we also look into a
social agents between no amount of after
what we do is that we can treat each
multiplexer that's a feature right and
simply way is the binary feature and
then each basically each protein can be
described area but by vector field wall
emotive a thong and visa blender we can
use association or feature selection of
Augustana College we have tried to see
you rather know you're strong
association among different motifs and
and we find some of them and that they
have their now either we call them might
have motive
but yeah yes yes how does that how does
that correlate with known active site
have you tried to do a correlation
between your automatic you're sort of
computational method of finding small
motifs because the protein data bank is
already labeled with active site right
and so there are many many active sites
that are known and their functions are
known and then and then I all just look
for those active sites society what is
the relationship have you tried to
combine the two spatial motifs with
biological active sites to improve your
your discovery process this is a good
good point and what we have been doing
is that when we we did this
intentionally just to prove to Ballard
is that this is a quite effective way to
combine the station tips and provide
them with with some a nice hypothesis to
test and so when we do the manually we
didn't incorporate that knowledge we
just read all the residue of the face
and look at their genetic her features
and and see whether or not we can find
special motif exactly and then after
that we validate each of our bigger more
fish than that and again some domain
knowledge and some of them are I mean
for yourself think available at pvp them
that either we look at them and some of
my students will spend a lot of time to
just look into the on the papers
available from PubMed to see whether
NASA there's some explanation is
somebody's paper there happen to record
okay here's the personified or hear some
some interesting things going on and
then that some and that what we have
been doing our of course our next step
would be like
who we start to think about this the
waist like to incorporate domain
knowledge into the mining exercise so
that's how something on our agenda but
so we haven't forget it to finish via
text actually we're a visit or a danger
to what we're doing is the the the
little demo i showed you if there is a
way that we are learn to protein
structures are and we are in the summer
we have been starting to work like to
build a nice girl and a a systematic way
to align multiple structures and and
with the which we go i'll provide a user
with a nice visualization feeling so
that they can they can for all the same
motif thank you